When my husband passed I thought I saw
him everywhere it was just so hard.
Does mark ever think he sees her? Hey guys,
Pete here. Today I'll be talking about Severance
episode 7. More major developments unfolded in
"Defiant Jazz" and I have to say that I loved them
all equally. we lost one of my favorite innies
and that's not the biggest thing that happened,
that's not even the only major
character death there was
and this is good we can use this. Milchick
delivers one of his best all-time lines
"the music dance experience
is officially cancelled"
and i'm not even sure that was the second best
line in the episode. there's outie stuff innie
stuff severed non-severed it's a lot to take in
and we also had the release of the "Lexington
Letter" companion book in between episodes. i'll
be recapping the highlights and what i think it
all means right after this quick spoiler warning.
if you haven't watched severance season 1 episode
7 yet then this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it. i think
that we should just start out with the ending
because i've seen this i've thought about this
and i really don't know what to make of it in
the closing sequence after getting really drunk
and probably scaring Alexa away for good Mark
tapes back together the photo of his wife that
he tore up earlier and while he's doing that he's
saying all the things that he loved about her
which sounded a lot like how they have their audis
described to them when they do a wellness session
that's also when they're encouraged not to react
to any of the facts because they're supposed to
enjoy them all equally without preference and
of course at the end he says he loves all those
things about her equally it turns out when we look
at the picture that his wife looks exactly like
Ms Casey and that's where things get confusing
because it does seem that his wife died in a car
crash it feels like a pretty elaborate thing to
fake considering his family believes that we hear
devin talking about it just in this episode and
maybe more than that he seems to be mourning her
not so much in the way that she decided to leave
him and say become a permanently severed employee
either way there's someone who's labeled as a
part-time severed employee who looks exactly
like his wife and Harmony Cobel seems to be
trying to figure out if he remembers her or
if they recognize each other but it's hard to say
why so i'm interested to hear what you guys think
about this please let me know in the comments i
know this got spoiled in the subreddit a couple
of weeks ago so maybe you've been thinking about
it a little bit longer i went back to look for
clues and beyond miss casey's strange behavior
that seems to be somewhat consistent with newborn
any behavior her being color coordinated
with the candle in mark's wellness session
and petey's claim that some severed employees
never leave the building harmony questioning if
mark ever sees her in this episode is probably
the biggest one that just kind of continues to
add to the mystery that surrounds her more than it
hints at what's going on with gemma and i do have
to get into everything else that happened so i'll
come back around to this at the end the opening
sequence picks up where we left mark at the end
of the last episode we get some introduction to
this character that greener and Cobel refer to as
Raghabi she tells mark that she's the person that
implanted his chip and that she's still the only
person that can deactivate it for what it's worth
she's not the person that implanted heli's she
claims that petey wouldn't have died if he just
followed her post-op instructions instead of
running away she hints that mark could also be
reintegrated without those same complications
and she does talk to him about his innie sum
saying that he's only been severed for two years
so he's in he's still a baby and that he brought
him into this world without his permission based
on his own desire for emotional convenience
before they can get too much into that Graner does
show up and mark doesn't recognize him because his
audi's never met him before they have a chance
to get acquainted Raghabi comes up behind him
and hits him over the head with the baseball bat
until he's dead of course this freaks mark out
and it doesn't help when she explains that he
was the head of security on the severed floor
she pulls Graner's security card out and gives
it to him explaining that it has full access
and it can't be tied to anyone she wants him to
take it to work tomorrow saying that his innie
will know what to do with it and i thought it
stood out that she said that i think you want
to do what's right and then added both of you she
did tell mark not to throw up because of his dna
and as soon as he makes it outside he does that
which may be something that we need to remember
when he goes back home he strips down to get
rid of all of his clothes like she told him
and alexa is still there while he was gone she
woke up realized that he left the house and he
has to make up a story about needing to get out
and drive around because he's not comfortable with
what happened between them the next morning he
grabs the key card and puts the plastic bag with
his clothes in with the rest of his trash right
on top which kind of seems like a bad idea we
also see mrs selvig on her way out and she makes a
comment about how he usually puts his trash out in
the afternoon Milchick has a big day ahead of him
at the office since harmony is moonlighting over
at Devon's place and Graner well he's not going to
be showing up he checks the new door that's there
to keep mdr safely situated and he retrieves
the ideographic card that dylan stole from ond
he goes there next to return the missing 7199g and
tells bert that they can now focus on the final
preparations which i was thinking was related to
their department's work whatever they're doing
with these cards but it's a little unclear because
he's also putting together any bert's retirement
party which i suppose you could also call his
pre-death celebration when dylan comes down he
wants to know what happened when he woke up at his
house it's explained to him that this is called
the overtime contingency which is a safeguard they
occasionally employ to wake up workers remotely
off-site dylan makes it clear that the innies had
no idea that they could do that and then he asked
about the boy that he saw wondering if it's his
son milchick tells him that he shouldn't tell his
co-workers about the otc and when dylan presses
him for his son's name he tells him that not
knowing is probably for the best based on how he
looks it appears that no amount of special perks
can take his mind off of it you see that he's
stewing at his desk irv is really worried about
bert and no one feels great about being locked
inside their office things take a brief turn
when milcheck starts the musical dance experience
helly gets to choose the genre and an accessory
and the musical genre names are hilarious
she goes with the maraca and defiant jazz
there are special lights and milcek starts out
dancing with helly and i don't suppose you could
watch this scene without making a comment about
how good he is at it and generally everyone's
enjoying this and looks happy except for dylan who
stayed at his desk and when milcek goes up behind
him he looks like he's seething he starts to see
images of his son calling him daddy from the night
before and then he starts to scream he gets
up and tackles milcheck into the record player
and yells tell me his name over and over as he
chokes him he then bites his shoulder to the
point of breaking the skin until the rest of them
pull him off miltek tries to threaten to report
him but then he realizes dylan would be happy
to go and talk to her about being woken up at
home after he's gone dylan tells the others that
they can wake them up he tells them the story he
tells them about the overtime contingency and says
that he keeps reliving the memory and now he has
to have that in his head without ever being able
to see him again irv tries to say that it's his
audi son but it doesn't fly he's completely pissed
off and heli decides that this is good that they
can use it she thinks they should try to find
out how they do it and then do it to themselves
they'd be able to get a chance to see the outside
world and learn who their audies really are the
one big problem is they can't get access and mark
shows them that he has grainer's security card
explaining that he has no idea why his audi
would have it petey had located the office
during a fire drill and showed mark so he knows
where it is they tried the key on the door and it
does work and they leave dylan there so the
rest of them can go to the office together
as soon as they get into the hall though irv
bales because he has to go find bert mark and
helly are able to get inside the office and they
find that no one's working inside they get a peek
behind the curtain and there's a lot of monitoring
equipment that looks custom if not slightly dated
to me it looks more analog than digital but there
are computers involved there's a bunch of displays
with employee names in their departments and
they have numbers next to their names that change
for the departments there are several we've
never heard of like cl wn w and a dnr and a
few more o and d is noticeably missing on the main
wall and considering that the only mdr employees
are the four we know that are listed there it's
likely that this list of over 80 names are all
the severed employees from this location while
they're snooping around they see that harmony
is descending in the non-severed elevator so
heli tears out the instructions for the overtime
contingency protocol and they leave when they get
back to the office they look those over and they'd
think that they can probably do it but one of
them is gonna have to stay behind dylan volunteers
since he's been out already and the only hit seems
to be that it's designed to be a two-man operation
there are two switches they have to flip but dylan
assures them he can do it and this does make you
wonder who was there to help grenor whenever
they woke him up when harmony arrives at her
office she finds natalie there waiting for her
with the board on her headset she explains that
doug greener is dead and that the board finds this
deeply troubling cobell says whoever killed grener
is probably the same person who reintegrated
peter kilmer but she doesn't go any further
because she says that integration happened and
she has the data to prove it and she wants to
leverage that to get an in-person meeting with
the board without intermediaries they do agree
to this and tell her that they'll be available to
meet with her at the egan family gala next week
i mentioned that irv was on his way to omd to see
bert and there's a shot with him walking down the
hall where he pulls out his mustache comb and
things start to feel like something bad's gonna
happen and it does when he arrives he learns
that they're having a going away party for bert
and that his innie is essentially dying he's
being retired milcheck wheels in a tv so he
can watch a hilarious message from his audi and he
notices that irv somehow managed to get out of mdr
the video is awkward and he continuously mentions
how he has no idea about what's happening there
while at the same time saying he will remember
them forever and we do hear him mention that he's
been doing the job for seven years obviously
irv is crushed the whole world is crushed i
think after watching this and he says out loud
you're all just gonna stand here and let him die
he questions if they're being punished and
milcheck assures him that it's just about burt's
audi retiring that it'll happen to him too and i
don't know it seems like it's pretty weird timing
irv delivers the best line of the episode when
he says you smug [ __ ] you're not severed you
walk out of here with your memories there's an
argument but bert convinces miltek to let him stay
they play the song he selected good morning
yesterday by paul anka and everyone shakes
his hand goodbye after he has his turn milcheck
walks her back to mdr and when he gets back to his
colleagues he tells them let's burn this place
to the ground and since i already talked about
the ending in the beginning that's pretty much
everything that happened in the episode the one
thing i haven't touched on yet though was the
interaction with devin and mrs selvig because
i just noticed something after i read the book and
i guess i'm a little bit dim but it hadn't dawned
on me that part of them having funny names like
helly and petey are related to the fact that their
innies are like children in the book the main
character mentions that her innie was called peggy
which was a name she hadn't been called since
she was a child and so i was thinking about them
talking about how gabby didn't remember her from
the birthing retreat and her bringing up the idea
of her being severed and it just stood out that
she introduced herself as gabby which might be an
indication that it wasn't any that she was talking
to another stellar episode from my point of view
last week managed to get me excited for what was
to come while it was one of the weaker episodes
overall sort of a transition and i think this was
an improvement there were a few things that felt
a little too convenient like the security card
but one of the things i've always liked about
this show is its ability to keep me engaged to the
point where i'm willing to overlook some things i
think the structure and pace have felt deliberate
and i'm expecting that things will continue to get
more intense right up until the very end it felt
like we were moving towards revolution i could
have never guessed that they were going to be able
to wake themselves up outside but that sounds like
a pretty good way to go there's a popular theory
out there that heli is an eagan she's a member of
the family or something along those lines although
we do know that her last name is riggs for what
that's worth but it all comes from her insistence
on keeping her annie there her inflexibility to
let her go even after she tried to kill herself
which you know there has to be a reason for that
i'm not sure if it's the case that she's part of
the family i think there's just as many clues that
go against it as there are for it but this
mention of the upcoming egan family gala did
make me wonder considering they have this plan to
wake themselves up and if that happens that seems
like a pretty crazy place for that to go down as
far as other theories i've never been too keen
on the one where they are a part of an experiment
or the severed employees are basically working on
themselves they're editing their code or balancing
their four tempers in kierspeak i think each week
that feels less likely and i don't know what the
work is but after reading the book i do think
it's somewhat important to lumen like they are
actually being productive i'm not sure it's as
nefarious as peggy k who was able to get coded
messages to her audi thinks it is and i'm not
sure we'll even understand what it is by the end
of the season but i do think that the work matters
and if you want to go into wild speculation
which is something i don't generally get into
if there's something to what peggy's saying
basically she thinks that they're doing corporate
espionage those cards that were so important
those could be something that you could pass off
to severed employees at different companies like
your competitors we do know that lumen isn't the
only company in this world that does it and they
could cause a problem think about how mdr reacted
to reading ricken's book if you had this childlike
experiential reality that they have and you had
these cards with instructions that could possibly
make it through the code detectors then you might
start acting funny i still feel like we're missing
a lot and trying to understand lumen's motivations
kier obviously was interested in his personal
legacy his business and his family legacy that's
intertwined with that we don't know if he was
a snake oil salesman that built a giant company
or if he was a weirdo that was trying to create
a giant cult or if he was both harmony is part of
our connection to that because she seems to be
really motivated both inside and out to seeing
this dream be realized i got the sense that
she's never been in the presence of the board
and i'm looking forward to seeing how that plays
out everything that she does related to mark is
just kind of a question and certainly the reveal
that gemma is mrs casey in some way or another
doesn't clear that up for me the robot theory is
looking a little more likely though i mean like i
said at the beginning i don't know what's going on
there none of the ideas i come up with sound great
it doesn't mean none of them would work but they
don't inspire confidence i will say that because
burt and erv didn't kiss that this magical
relationship that they built up in this season
ended with a handshake i suspect that we're gonna
see him again i've never been a fan of the idea
that they know each other in the outside world but
i mean there is the possibility that they could
meet out there i just feel like it's gonna happen
that any herb will see bert again and to be clear
where we left it that shouldn't be possible if he
retired so at this point i'm mostly rambling so i
will wrap it up i think this is probably a good
place to leave things i would recommend reading
through the book there's some interesting stuff in
there and it's short you can get right through it
i'll put links in the video description even if
you don't live in the us or don't have an apple
device you can still read it so let me know in
the comments what you thought about this episode
where you think things are going what theories
are you latching on to and which musical genre
would you pick in the musical dance experience
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon